the school of life has branches all
around the world but till now it hasn't
been directly involved in the US but now
we're coming with a big three-day
conference that we're going to be
running in San Francisco starting on the
23rd of March 2018 taking place in the
beautiful Yerba Buena Center right in
the heart of San Francisco this is a
three-day event about everything we care
about at the School of Life emotional
intelligence wisdom self understanding
love friendship and meaning the
conference will mirror what happened in
our first conference in Lisbon Portugal
in October 2017 that means we'll have
lectures in the day great meals together
the best kind of interactions and chats
about everything that matters late into
the night it'll be a true chance to
experience of globally minded community
dedicated to learning kindness self
exploration and wisdom the conference
lasts three days and is led by our
founder and creative lead Alain de
Botton and will feature our best
teachers and our very best most
transformative ideas if you're
interested in coming to San Francisco to
meet us at the end of March please click
on the link on the screen now to find
out more you'll learn a lot returned
with a huge number of reusable new ideas
and make friends for life we hope to see
you there